avis de tempête sur plaisir ce dimanche
16 février l'équipe locale en difficulté
en fédérale 2 recevait sous les
bourrasques de vent un autre prétendant
la descente gennevillois après avoir
concédé l'ouverture du score les
plaisirs aux arts réagissent et
reviennent dans le match avec deux
pénalités et un essai le score à la
pause 11 à 7
la première période on a choisi de jouer
avec le vent maintenant c'était pas
c'était pas forcément au final un autre
avantage parce que bas le score est pas
si significatif que ça à la mi temps et
on avait choisi de jouer avec le vent
pour pour justement prendre un avantage
un peu plus important en deuxième
période plaisir accentue son avance
malgré quelques frayeurs en fin de match
une bagarre générale plaisir l'emportent
sur le score de 18 à 12
mon sentiment c'est que c'était le plus
beau match de la saison après les
conditions c'est sûr faisait que ça
rendait les choses un peu plus compliqué
beaucoup de vent mais bon sang on est
quand même bien sorti et et ça donne une
grosse bouffée d'oxygène pour la suite à
saison donc ça fait du bien quand une
bouffée d'oxygène qui se traduit au
classement plaisir dernier il ya
quelques semaines remonte à la 9e place
avec deux points d'avancé sur son
adversaire du jour
c'est la première fois de l'année qu'on
enchaîne de bons résultats 2 victoires
donc voilà j'espère que la dynamique va
pas s'arrêter à ces deux matches et puis
qu'on va pouvoir continuer à engranger
des points et prendre un peu de
confiance quoi maintenant
j'ai un groupe qui est ambitieux j'ai
des joueurs qui sont ambitieux donc on
ira jusqu où on pourra aller avec grand
plaisir
pour continuer sa série de victoires
plaisir se déplacera sur le terrain de
beauvais ce dimanche 23 février le
deuxième de la poule
[Applaudissements]